foreign
[Music]
and that's why this is such an important
decision because it is one that will
follow you now and into the future
and that concludes another traditional
Yale information session there will be a
guided tour beginning in 15 minutes in
the meantime I'd be happy to answer any
questions you may have
yes
um when was Yale founded
great question uh Yale was founded in
oh yes you is there that all yellow
professors teach another great question
uh it is true that every 10-year
professor in Yale College teaches
undergraduates so even a freshman might
be taking a class from a Nobel Prize
winner oh
any more questions
yeah
I have a question
why did you choose Yale
[Music]
when I was a senior in high school
college is called touch my name every
day I debate
where to matriculate but every place
seemed the same yet after I went through
the options
only one choice
remained I wanted to hail from a college
called yeah
now let me explain
it's a place where you're on
quintessential knowledge you can live in
a residential college and you can put
your hearts into all the liberal arts
and that's why I chose yeah
of course you'll get a first-rate
education but also thrive on class with
conversations here is where we threat
tears dies
and that's why I chose yeah
[Music]
one of the reasons I chose Yale was for
its housing system before students
arrive as freshmen they're randomly
assigned to one of 12 smaller
communities called residential colleges
these colleges have nothing to do with
academic subjects or extracurricular
activities
but rest assured they're quite a bit
more than just living spaces
excuse me the admissions officer tell us
a bit more about residential colleges
sure thing
students here at Yale come from
everywhere around
every type of interest that could
possibly be found to our passions divide
us know our colleges provide us
family and Common Ground
for all four years we'll all reside
together in colleges United by Pride
with such great facilities to hone your
abilities you'll never want to go
outside
[Music]
every college has a dining hall with a
salad bar and grill and organic options
for every meal I'm gonna eat my food
each one has common room which we could
not live without to study or to meet in
groups or simply to hang out
and when the dining Halls are closed
this butter is for snacks and if you
need a study break those game rooms to
relax
Library without stepping but outside I'm
just right down the hallway my clothes
are washed and dried I work out in my
College gym a mirror two floors below
then I meet my friends for rehearsal in
the dance studio
there are tons of Music practice rooms
where I can hone my skills
we even have a movie theater this one
always gives me chills
we don't have normal dorms at Yale
instead we live in swedes so you may
have a roommate
[Music]
head of every college is a master and
dating
they live with us and eat with us and
everything between am I taking the right
class will these credits suffice I've
got the flu can I get some advice what's
a good summer programs
[Music]
a master brings us all together as our
senior Prof posting study breaks and
lectures for when we need time off
like to see a Broadway show I'll gladly
subsidized let's host another concert
I'll proudly harmonize
free food in the evening for all of you
and share
and a master's keeper tomorrow too I
hope to see you there
a chance to see all your favorite
celebrities hear their stories and ask
advice which is why I had to interview
him twice
a place
[Music]
that's why I chose yeah
Yale
but when you do step outside your
Residential College who knows what you
might run into
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
but mostly I chose Yale
for its superb academic opportunities
I came to Yale because I wanted to learn
and I wanted to learn from the best
memorizing figures and facts just to
pass another test
last year I spent the summer abroad I
helped to monitor a foreign election and
now a volunteer at a law school Clinic
on human rights protection I Wanna Be An
Architect someday I wanna help save a
city that's dying that's why I needed a
school that would push me to see that my
coursework has the grounding in reality
now I craft a bigger picture my
perspective has a different scale
that's why I chose yeah
[Applause]
I came to Yale from across the world
because I wanted a global education now
I'm bringing clean water to the
countries that made it through the
Easter with Africa Foundation
in a class called philosophy of art you
see where truth and Beauty connect what
is the concept about it why should we
care where do Play-Doh and Picasso
intercept a study real world problems
[Music]
here
foreign languages it's only a question
well as your freshman counselor I was
chosen by the
Bible I'm a senior in this college and I
know just what you mean the first two
weeks
[Music]
so Epsom was the first to put real life
on the stage what what about William
Shakespeare what oh it's a nice point
then we will meet again at nine and I
should have a drafting paper ready by
them so are you using the heterogeneous
Catalyst or the homogeneous catalyst for
this reaction
[Music]
and when it's time to study for that
intensive course and you're looking for
the perfect results
[Music]
[Applause]
do you mind
this is a library
sorry
[Applause]
campus tradition the students are very
evil and the classes are small so go
audition all your courses
in science or in chemistry or as a
musician meet your professors over
coffee or dinner with their you're
sure to be an academic winner
residential colleges experience
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
cats was better
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign